foreign
[Music]
that was great I Dracula is taking a
bite out of Vegas with the help of the
Nevada Ballet Theater their new show is
coming in October and here to tell us
the dark details artistic director Roy
Kaiser so let's start that was beautiful
by the way thank you really felt thank
you I felt like I was there so why did
you choose this reproduction that we
brought to the Smith Center in 2018 okay
okay so now it's backed by popular
demand okay I mean people loved this
show and it's um choreographed by Ben
Stevenson a very well-known
choreographer who is uh very Adept at
creating theater an atmosphere yeah so
this has everything this has Dracula of
course of course in all of his glory he
has 19 Brides In the First Act they're
singing it right there yes yes
um the costumes costumes are amazing the
whole production is really beautifully
done fog to create a little Ambiance
right right and
um flying flying yeah so there's
acrobatics it's very Vegas of you guys
um now
after hearing that it feels like the
audience will feel like they're also on
stage I hope so I hope it's very
immersive experience it just pulls them
in and they feel like they're right
there with the performers that that
makes a great performance and I'm
hearing that I'm hearing the music now
as well let's talk about the music score
because that is also just equally as
important music is compiled uh by the
music by the composer list Franz litz
and it um and it's perfect if you know
his music at all or kind of an overview
of his music it's mysterious and Moody
and it has all of these different
qualities that help the artists the
performers really convey the story right
um without speaking that's so beautiful
um and what about the actors and the
dancers on stage you know what was it
like for them to bring this to life oh
they're having a great time we've been
rehearsing for about four weeks now five
weeks and uh we have a lot of new
additions to the company this year which
is really exciting uh we have uh 24
dancers in the company and about half of
them are new arrivals it's amazing very
talented dancers from all over so this
is the first time they're experiencing
this so they're even like more they're
ready they're ready they're ready for
their four performances tell everybody
when they can catch this dramatic
beautiful October 6th through the night
okay at the Smith Center at the Smith
s theaters back yes and there are still
tickets available okay so spread the
word you have to come see us oh I would
love to okay I would love to I might be
so into it I'm like
engage and start doing some ballet
new place for you the Nevada ballet's
Dracula has four performances again
happening from Thursday October 6th
through the 9th at the Smith Center for
the Performing Arts for a full
performance schedule as well as to
purchase those tickets that are still
available just head to nevadavalet.org
I